I think it is fair to say that the
national scene in general and the
federal government in particular are the
focus of most political and citizen
efforts today liberals still call for
massive federal government infusions
over federal infusions of inflated
generated dollars to solve every
conceivable problem even conservative
and libertarian critics increasingly
fall into the trap of focusing almost
exclusively on the national scene life
is a source of our problems and as a
place to make a difference it is time to
question that assumption and to prove
that it is wrong some of you may
recognize that as the words of
entrepreneur and philanthropist William
E Simon from his forward to cutting back
City Hall Bob pools seminal examination
of the problem of local government
overreach and exposition of solutions
published in nineteen eighty many of its
descriptions read as though they were
written yesterday after explaining that
from 1967 through 1976 city government
revenues nationwide increased 187
percent Bob notes that the city's era of
free spending is over this has been made
even clearer by the spectacle of actor
of our major cities New York and
Cleveland both reaching a condition of
bankruptcy successive administration's
of both cities thought they could spend
their way out of trouble only to
discover the era of limits in an
especially painful way does that sound
familiar well since 2010 several cities
have applied for bankruptcy protection
including San Bernardino in Stockton in
California and Harrisburg in
Pennsylvania in 1980 the era of free
spending really was over at least
temporarily citizens had already
unleashed a barrage of ballot
initiatives designed to cut taxes these
began as so many experiments in
government begin in California with
proposition 13 which limited property
taxes to 11 percent of the assessed
value and limited increases of that ties
to two percent per year
the following year 21 other states cut
property taxes in a revolution that has
been viewed by some as priests aging
Reagan's in the context of such tax cuts
Bob's book provided very practical
advice which in many cases drew on
diverse existing practices as to how to
cut local spending but put these into
three categories privatization user
charges and thinking smarter a catch-all
term relating to a better management the
book contains chapters on pretty much
every local government function police
criminal justice fire protection
emergency ambulance service garbage and
solid waste leisure and recreational
services transit systems social services
in health care planning and zoning
public work city management and schools
in the intervening years most of Bob's
advice has been adopted in one place or
another both domestically and
internationally today we're going to
talk about a few examples of the
application of these ideas describing
reasons past current and future role we
will begin our work with our work on
enhancing personal mobility over taejun
thanks Julian so Julie and I have worked
out a set of stories we're going to tell
and the first is is atlanta and in
atlanta transportation in particular
five almost six years ago now a fellow
named Bob Galvin is the former CEO of
Motorola came to reason and said I've
spent a lot of time thinking about and
about congestion in our cities because I
build factories and I hire people by the
thousands and I see the effects of
congestion on my business and when I
extrapolate that to the economy I
realized that we have a huge problem
that nobody really is recognizing and it
needs to be solved and he wanted to help
reason to come up with solutions and so
we go VIN to that and partnered with a
lot of smart transportation people
outside of reason as well as our own
team and developed ideas and solutions
for how major metropolitan areas in the
United States could
build out a transportation system over a
couple of decades that would actually
reduce congestion because every single
major metropolitan area in the United
States right right now has a long-range
transportation plan that's required by
the federal government in order to get
federal money and every single one of
them predicts spending billions of
dollars over 25 years and for congestion
to get worse and a lot of you have heard
me my outrage on that before it's just
amazing that we actually have a plan for
things to get to spend money and for
things to get worse and why don't we
have a plan for how to spend money and
things actually get better well to make
the ideas that we develop more concrete
we've decided to build out actual
detailed plans for a number of cities
and the first one we did was Atlanta and
we proposed a network of hot lanes on
all of the major freeways in the Atlanta
area a major new tunnel freeway
paralleling the most congested
north-south freeway through the downtown
area completing some missing links in
sort of the network around the city
including another major tunnel project
so a set of projects that if they were
built and if they were told with
congestion pricing as a choice so all
the free roads would still exist but we
would add on to that a whole bunch of
told roads you would create more choices
for people and you would dramatically
reduce congestion especially relative to
the current plan and so lana was our
first we went on some other cities in
Atlanta in particular we rolled out this
study right at a time when the city was
rolling out their long-range update to
their long-range plan which was all
about building a bunch of interesting
new commuter rail transit lines and and
so forth and their plan was very
explicitly to spend fifty percent of the
money on about five percent of the
travelers and therefore to spend about
fifty percent of the money on
ninety-five percent of the travelers and
we pointed out well that might not be
sustainable and that may be what you
want to do is actually spend the money
you know somewhat relative to the way
people actually travel and thereby
improve travel for most people rather
than say you know what we're going to do
ninety-five percent of the people to an
ever worsening transportation situation
and five percent of the people will get
a little bit better deal we were lucky
there in every city where we do this we
look for someone a local leader to
really pick up the standard and the
fellow who was then the chairman of the
State Transportation Commission of
filling Vance Smith loved our plan
really championed it and in fairly short
order within a couple of years we had
the two most important elements of our
plan incorporated into the official
government plan and that was the hot
networks the hot lane networks and one
of the tunnel projects and the two most
interesting things that to say about
that is one the first segment of the new
hot lanes opened last year so what we
proposed for years ago is now the first
element has been built and is open so
we're very very excited about that it's
been successful in its first four months
five months now maybe four months 13
months oh okay Wow okay yeah I'm
confusing the Miami lanes ago it's and
so it's been successful it had some real
birthing pains that was very interesting
we're bucking a governor who is you know
he's one of those interesting and all
too often seen you know Republicans who
loves markets except for the markets he
doesn't like and he doesn't see how the
private sector can do anything good in
transportation apparently so so we're
bucking up against that but the first
elements of the planner in place they're
successful I think they're they're
starting to convince people we had an
interesting breakthrough on the tunnels
we proposed because the first reaction
whenever we talk about building tells is
what's too expensive we can't
do that and you know the the fact that
that we've been crunching the numbers
and looking at the costs and benefits
and adding up how you could pay for
these tunnels takes a while to soak in
but in Atlanta's case what was great was
they was actually a project in the city
going on at the time we proposed this to
build a gigantic new sewer tunnel and so
we arranged with some local groups for a
bunch of the transportation folks to go
on a tour of that sewer tunnel less is
an 18-foot sewer tunnel so more than big
enough to drive cars through and when
they saw that this tunnel was being
built without anybody even really
knowing about it it was just well yeah
you can't do sewers without big tunnels
down there were like oh well maybe
building a tunnel isn't so crazy after
all so it was that that visual for them
was so much more compelling than all the
numbers we could throw at him so Atlanta
has been a success in terms of adopting
the things we proposed politically it
remains challenging last year they they
had a ballot proposition to raise sales
taxes in the city sorry in the state and
fund again the old plan so they wanted
to raise a lot of money to fund a bunch
of rail transit projects and we were
very active one of our staff Brooke
Feigenbaum is actually located in
Atlanta and he worked with the the
state-based free free market think tank
there and really took on that tax
increase and the voters voted it down
which was a great victory and now it's
it's back to considering what to do
going forward and and our plan is front
and center again Baruch and the state
based think tank are actually releasing
an update to our now almost five year
old plan so updating it with all the new
numbers and the new stories and sort of
push push pushing to get what really is
a 25-year vision for improved
transportation in Atlanta implemented
there it's and so needless to say we're
only five years into that process we're
done the same thing in miami and miami
is probably our second most successful
place bought everybody most you
no bob is in the Miami area we have a
Miami plan and Bob is having great
success at getting the powers that be
there to start adopting pieces of our
plan we've released a plan in the Fort
Myers Florida area where they're also
have incorporated into their plan some
of the things we proposed and we just
released this last year Chicago's plan
they haven't adopted he of it yet but
but I was actually just last week at a
northwestern university conference with
all of the transportation planners for
the Chicago area and we had some very
productive discussions and they were a
lot less skeptical now than they were
last August so in just six months we've
made progress we're coming out soon with
plans for Los Angeles and Denver in the
next year year and a half as well and
we're going to keep pushing in Atlanta
other places so that that process of
developing the ideas and then working
with the policymakers to hash out the
details and get pieces of the plan
implemented is it's fundamental to that
project Thank You Adrienne I'm i wanna i
want now to talk about trash in coming
back city hall or pool described for
ways in which trash could be collected
by the city itself that's municipal
collection public collection by a single
firm hired by the city that's contract
collection by several private firms that
had exclusive locations where they could
pick up trash but would charge me Trent
privately and by completing private
firms with no government involvement
except possibly licensing and that's
pure private collection he asked the
question what which of these is best
well first of all he offered an anecdote
in 1979 New York City's twice-weekly
unionized municipal run trash
collections cost each resident 202 h
home sorry two hundred ninety seven
dollars per year that's real money back
in 1979 meanwhile 20 miles away in
bellerose queens a private contractor
was providing thrice-weekly three times
a week collection for seventy two
dollars a year
the anecdote speaks for itself but Bob
then cites evidence that contract and
franchise operations with at least
costly for cities of all size but for
cities over 550 thousand people the
difference was enormous with municipal
collection costing sixty-eight percent
more on average than contract firm in
later work for reason Lin Scarlett
explains why this is compared with
municipal trash collectors private
contractors require more work from
employers employees offer equivalent
salaries but fewer benefits match skill
levels with job requirements use part
time labor when appropriate require that
managers be responsible for equipment
and labor availability allow first-line
supervisors to have hiring and firing
Authority use incentive pay systems and
use less labor-intensive means of
providing a given service the bottom
line is incentives matter and private
companies have much stronger incentive
to contain costs than public companies
perhaps this explains why even in 1978
only about a quarter of municipalities
surveys used municipal collection
forty-three percent had contract or
franchise collection and thirty percent
had private collection but ironically
many of the large municipalities
including New York and Los Angeles Ram
municipal collection guaranteeing their
residents poor and expensive service as
a result some estimates for the total
volume of trash under municipal
collections around seventy percent in
those of times following Bob's early
work on this reason undertook a slew of
studies analyzing the costs of private
versus public collection as well as
polishing how-to guides for public
officials explaining how to cut costs
through privatization and it worked at
least in part in the years since the
volume of trash collected privately has
steadily risen while precise numbers
remain elusive the ratio of municipal to
private collection by volume has more or
less reversed with seventy percent being
collected privately and only thirty
percent publicly even Morris County New
Jersey where I now live has been
gradually privatizing its waste
management town by town sadly New York
and LA still operate municipal
collection but at least la introduced
user fees one of the ideas that Bob
advocated which cover the costs of trash
collection and disposal since 2008 the
annual cost for a single-family home in
LA has been four hundred thirty-five
dollars 84 cents all households in
multiple dwellings pay 291 dollars and
ninety six cents by contrast in 2012
each household in New York City paid
about seven hundred dollars for its
trash to be collected out of general
taxes so in the more dense urban
population you charging considerably
more because of the municipal non user
fee based system but another phenomenon
has occurred in the past 30 years an
obsession with recycling this had
already begun in 1979 when Bob was right
in cutting back City Hall he describes
increasing concerns about landfill
running out in the need to find
alternative disposal options being a
rational engineer Bob talked about
burning trash which in many cases does
make sense since heat recovery and it
was energy to be generated that partly
offsets the costs of separating waste
post-consumer other technologies
developed by private entrepreneurs mean
the post consumer separation now with a
combined with recycling and burning
often have a lower-cost alternative to
landfill but too many environmentalists
recycling is something that must be done
by the consumer that means separating
waste at source and having a separate
collection nevermind the fact that such
trash usually has to be sorted later
anyway because people are imperfect they
don't sort they don't sort accurately
and there's there's an eater to
differentiate subsequently that's
because the reason why environmentalists
believe that is because they think that
recycling is a moral issue not an
economic one and their objective is
ultimately to reduce consumption hence
their mantra reduce reuse recycle Lin
Scarlett's work for reason in the 90s
sought to combat this demented mantra in
particular she challenged the idea that
producers of packaged goods should be
forced to establish separate collection
and recycling programs for their
packaging this idea called extended
producer responsibility took hold in
Germany in the early 90s and spread
throughout Europe
fortunately Lynn was very successful
most attempts to implement extended
producer responsibility for packaging in
the United States floundered against her
barrage of logic unfortunately the same
cannot be said for municipal curbside
recycling programs which as your show of
hands indicated have flourished in spite
of their lack of economic or ecological
logic worse extended producer
responsibility is now beginning to rear
its head again and it is happening at
the municipal level reason is addressing
this problem in two ways first we're
undertaking research to assess the
impact of taxes and bans on bottled
water and we'll promote that research
widely second we are undertaking
research to investigate ways in which
municipalities can cut their waste
management costs based on available
evidence we expect to find the
competitive tendering for waste
collection combined in some cases at
least with post-consumer sorting and
recovery will be the most cost-effective
solution and might even increase total
recycling rates will then produce a
how-to guide offering advice to
municipalities about the best ways to
cut costs essentially what we did in it
with live in the 1990s and we aim to
engage directly with the municipalities
promoting this guide targeting
especially those contemplating the
implementation of an extended producer
responsibility program if I'm right and
we are successful that second collection
for recycling may become a thing of the
past and our local taxes and waste
management fees will fall commensurately
thanks Julian so I'm going to shift to a
broader privatization some of you have
seen our video on Sandy Springs Georgia
or heard Lynn talk at reason weekend in
the past about sandy springs so for
those of you not familiar with Sandy
Springs Sandy Springs is a city and
relatively new city outside of Atlanta
suburb of Atlanta that was an
unincorporated part of a county where
the folks were very dissatisfied with
the quality of services they got from
the county government and their
agitation
over the years had got them nowhere and
so they eventually incorporated
themselves created their own City and
the big innovation was they created the
city with an almost entirely privatized
government under state law they had have
a government police and fire department
and everything else is privatized they
have ten staff and those ten staffer
essentially just manage the contract
with the private company that does
everything except for police and fire as
well as as you know that supports the
City Council you still have an elected
City Council now the way this happened
is a combination of that unrest the
opportunity finally to incorporate and
this one guy one guy who was is a olive
reporter is at that point at all ready
retired had worked in a lot of different
city governments lived in the area liked
this idea at the beginning he like
everybody else was really focused on
getting their own city so they could
control their own destiny and it was
only once that process got started that
he thought well you know really we could
do this all with just a contract with
private companies we don't have to have
a whole city government and so he pushed
that idea and this sort of volunteer
process they had of creating this city
so it didn't take him very long once he
started thinking like that and talking
to others and getting you know some
positive feedback well maybe we should
explore that he looked around and came
across reason saw what we had contact us
and I can remember flying out there for
a day of meetings and we were at a
company's the conference room and the
city was they had not yet had the vote
to incorporate so there's no official
city government but literally on 1201 am
on a date certain that once that vote
passes they have to have a city
government they are legally not allowed
to do any City business until 1201 am on
that first day but at 1201 am on their
first day they're supposed to have a
functioning city government so
I mean it was just like Joseph Heller it
was a catch-22 you could ridiculous and
so what they had to do was just do they
had to create a shadow government
essentially that was all volunteer and
unofficial that could then just start on
day one and then go through the process
of making everything legal so but to
keep it all clean we SAT there in this
conference room and we would talk with
some people and then they would leave
and then the next group would come in
and then they would leave and then the
next group because we couldn't get
everybody together because it would they
wanted to avoid potential conflicts of
interest so this very bizarre parade of
people but you know community leaders
and business leaders coming in to talk
about these privatization ideas and and
and through it all it was me and my
colleague at the time Jeff Siegel just
tapping into the wealth of work that
reason had done since Bob rope cutting
back City Hall after he wrote that book
reason commenced saying well let's
research every service area that state
and local governments do capture what is
known about what works and doesn't work
in government providing those services
find out where it's been privatized how
did that work what's the best example
what can they teach us what are the
lessons learn study after study after
study on every service you can think of
you know the you know there's a
ridiculous number of them and they're
all ridiculously detailed and but we
handle that and that was great because
they had to write an RFP that talked
about how you move the the paper
products the documents of the city from
point A to point B all the way up to how
you pave the streets and everything in
between every little my new detail that
goes into a city government had to be
covered in these contracts and it was
our stuff that broke down well here's
how these cities did it and what they
covered and we were able to bring in
people from cities you know when they
said well now we're writing the part on
trash
collection or now we're writing the part
on you know heating maintenance in the
city buildings or whatever it might be
they didn't have too many silly
buildings so that was easy but trimming
trees around the telephone lines you
know whatever it might be we could go
out and say okay well who's you know
according to we keep tabs on all of
these privatizations you know who's the
cutting edge out there can we arrange a
phone conference so they can tell them
how they tackle ball of these problems
and so months of this process of sharing
all of this information we accumulated
over a decade and a half two decades and
letting all that feed into this you know
telephone book size contract they
ultimately had but at the end of that
process they had a government with you
know outside the police and fire only
ten city employees and Oliver became the
first city manager and and it still
involved very much and he likes the
point I says you know all these cities
going bankrupt over pension problems and
we don't have any pensions because we
only have two probably only have ten
employees so they've avoided all of
those fiscal problems that have plagued
so many cities there's in almost every
dimension you could ask their services
have improved I mean that's really what
motivated that kind of the average man
on the street who had no ideological
care for this privatization stuff they
did have to vote on it and it did pass a
vote but I think the average person
really was more concerned about are we
finally going to get decently paved
streets and trash collected on time and
ambulances that get here in you know
five minutes instead of 25 minutes and
things like that that's what they really
cared about and they got that they got
vastly improved services I do think it's
a little bit of there's a little bit of
a lesson embedded in this for
libertarians and especially libertarians
who who who feel you know heart pangs
for a democracy that watching this city
be created in this sort of privatized
model and have an elected City Council a
city council that doesn't have very much
manage
to do because the private company is
taking care of everything all they have
is a contract and they have to make sure
that they're managing that contract but
that's relatively no work for the City
Council so what's a for City Council to
do they gotta meet couple times a month
they got to do something right because
you can't just go have a meeting and not
do something so unfortunately at least
from I'm not I don't live there but my
outside perspective is they've been all
too susceptible to the idea well there's
must be if there's a problem let's
regulate it and and so a bit of a
nothing else to do but pass regulations
so that's all they do is pass
regulations in its it's not ridiculous
and it's not you know it's not the most
regulated town around but but I just
watched that process and say you know if
you've got a democratically elected
government they are going to do things
and if it's not spend money which they
can't really spend much money then
they'll do other things and that's just
the nature unless you constrain if
they'd written a city charter that said
well we're going to have a city council
but you know sort of like the Bill of
Rights we're going to say they can only
do these things you know they had been
constrained in the Charter they might
have wound up being you know more
successful in that regard so for this
food for thought especially since the
main takeaway from all that for reason
was one the yeoman work we put in over
the years after cutting back City Hall
of digging into every municipal service
and knowing how they could all be
privatized really paid off in one bundle
in this particular case which just goes
to show that everywhere else where
they're trying to privatize just one of
those things you know we've had the
stuff that they need but this model both
has inspired a number of other
communities there is now half a dozen
other towns in other in Georgia and
other states that have essentially
replicated that model to some scale so
they've incorporated themselves as a
largely privatized city but when I'm
talking to you know any other town in
America and they're saying well gee were
not sir we can privatize our street
maintenance you know and like if you
look at Sandy Springs they privatized
everything really
they can privatize everything you
telling me there's so much more
competent down in Georgia than you are
here in Utah that you can't privatize
just street maintenance let's go can we
go on the radio and talk about that I
want you to confess to people know those
Georgians are way smarter than us but no
it's a it is it so it's a it's a beacon
in a sense that if they can do it this
large that the idea that you can't
privatize on some more modest Gail looks
pretty silly so it's it's a it's both a
model for privatized cities and just a
model for privatization and validate
sort of our approach of be having the
best examples and the context with the
people who've been there done that to
take to every new city that looks at
privatization thanks as you a side note
Adrian I talk to Oliver Porter about the
the reasons why they didn't privatize
fire and police but not something again
that Bob talks about in private isaac
video and which we have done some work
on it reason and and and he said that
the reason was a cost of insurance and
that if they had privatized they would
have been subject to potentially to
tortious liability an unlimited scale
which would have meant that they would
had to have taken out very very
expensive insurance on their on the
police and fire but when it's provided
by the government the police and fire
have indemnity so that's that's it's
kind of a sort of sad indictment
actually so it's not the statement
legislation per se but more the torque
system that's the problem I'm a little
now quickly about education an issue
that reasons been involved with very
intensively in the past few years in
cutting back City Hall Bob describes the
parlor state and high cost of education
in the late 1970s he notes that between
1950 and 1976 real per capita expendable
expenditure on education had risen
nearly threefold meanwhile rates of
functional illiteracy had risen
eleven percent to sixteen percent
incredibly so you triple them out you're
spending on education and literacy rates
decline moreover between 1964 1975
scores on sats had also fallen with the
proportion of students achieving over
600 on the verbal s80 falling thirty-six
percent and the proportion scoring over
700 falling forty-eight percent pumping
more money into education is not
necessarily the solution the problem
with our education system is essentially
one of a lack of competition with over
eighty percent of schools being run
directly by government and with pay and
other employment conditions being set by
negotiation with unions there is no real
mechanism to incentivize good teaching
don't get me wrong there are thousands
of well-meaning teachers in the state
sector there are even many good teachers
the problem is that the current system
doesn't provide appropriate rewards for
good teaching quite the opposite it
rewards mediocrity and years in service
while making extremely difficult to
punishing competence and it makes it
easy for teachers to retire early so
what we get is mediocrity along with a
vast and increasing pension obligation
Bob discussed several ways in which
choice and education might be increased
including education vouchers such
Raptors have actually existed since the
late 19th century but have generally
been used only very narrowly for example
in locations where population densities
were too low to support a public school
a modern version of the voucher
developed was developed by milton
friedman in the 1950s and this sought to
apply the idea more generally tax
dollars currently used for public
schools will be given instead to parents
as vouchers to be used to pay for
private schools since schools will be
able to keep any profit they would have
incentives to innovate driving up
quality and driving down costs hiring
good teachers firing bad ones better
schools would thrive where schools would
be work would go bust all will be taken
over several states including Wisconsin
Indiana and Louisiana have adopted
voucher programs others have adopted
related measures such as tax credits in
Florida and education savings accounts
in Arizona but none of these programs
are you
versal most of them target lower income
or poorly performing school districts
moreover in many states vouchers have
perhaps unsurprisingly been blocked by
teacher unions in the 90s reasons Lisa
Snell helped avert another way to
introduce competition education that was
less directly amenable to attack by
teachers unions because it seems to work
within the general structure of state
financed education called portability or
backpack funding the idea is to give
parents the choice over which public
school their school their kids attend
and then allocate funding in proportion
to the number of students enrolled so
that the money follows the child for
backpack funding to work however public
schools must be able to set their own
budgets and not be bound by all the
usual strictures on hiring firing and
compensating teachers in other words
they need to be structured as charter
schools in Louisiana and 95 law allowed
charter schools but was so restricted
that little choice emerged continual
abysmal failure of the school system
prompted a change in the law in 2003
that made it much easier to create
charter schools and empowered the
state's Board of Education to use
charters to replace failing schools in
2005 Hurricane Katrina devastated
Louisiana school system more than a
hundred public schools were closed
displacing approximately one hundred and
eighteen thousand school-aged children
throughout the state the state stepped
in to reopen schools encouraging school
choice by facilitating charters
including by adopting reasons idea of
workplace charter schools where by
corporations sponsor schools in exchange
for enrollment preferences for employees
children today in New Orleans nearly
sixty percent of the city's estimated
26,000 students are in charter schools
and test scores have risen dramatically
since 2005 in 2008 Lisa met with
government governor bobby jindal and his
superintendent of education to talk
about how to expand school choice and
competition further through backpack
funding she testified before the States
Commission on streamlining government on
backpack funding and the Commission
passed an immediate resolution directing
the State Board of elementary and
secondary education to pursue her
recommendations
Lisa then work with a state board on
implementing backpack funding including
Tiger teams of school finance experts
for three-putt symposia designed to help
school administrators and state
policymakers understand the model in
February 2011 Governor Jindal announced
a pilot project on that funding
involving seven school districts lisa is
now working closely with those districts
and the state to help with
implementation in the largest
sub-district Jefferson Parish she is
helping with the district-wide
implementation will eventually cover all
50,000 students already Jefferson Parish
has eliminated 259 central office
positions and redirected five million
dollars back to the schools in addition
to louisiana lisa has helped Nevada
devise a pilot portability program and
has teamed up with state based think
tank in Washington Pennsylvania and
Virginia to publish Studies on how they
could follow suit lisa is building on
these successes developing a fully
fledged educated intenta within reason
with the aim of encouraging more
meanness parties and states to follow
Louisiana's lead the center will develop
various materials including case studies
and how-to guides which will be
distributed in collaboration with state
think tanks around the country lisa and
others will then follow up with more
concrete advice to policymakers no doubt
more Tiger teams in the medium term we
foresee a tipping point where school
choice becomes mainstream leading many
municipalities and states to adopt heart
drop adopt part charters and portability
looking further down the line as the
trend continues private solutions will
begin to dominate first with education
vouchers in the SAS and eventually with
pure private provision our vision for
education but for now we must focus on
advocating the incremental changes that
are possible and identifying and working
with motivated positive policymakers to
implement them by increasing choice in
education we will extend freedom and
opportunity to our children and cut tax
dollars
i well the sort of last of our little
vignettes here has to do with circling
back to California you know there was a
time when Julian talked at the beginning
about prop 13 in California as there was
a time when California was a source of
good policy ideas like like limiting
limiting taxes but unfortunately
California followed not too long after
that with start is starting down the
path of becoming the pioneer of bad
ideas by far not the least being the
unionization of government workers and
one of the one of the unfortunate
consequences that little innovation rot
is a an explosion over a decade and a
half of hidden costs to state and local
governments in the form of pension and
health benefits for state workers a
decade ago just looking at local numbers
I could see for the this largest city
near me which is Bakersfield California
modest sized city I could see that in
2020 which is now a lot closer than it
was when I crunch those numbers that in
2020 the city's fire department would be
paying more to non-working firemen than
they would be paying to working firemen
because their annual pension costs would
be greater than their annual salary
costs by 2020 I mean this is a
ridiculously unsustainable system in
2006 looking more broadly reason
published a study called The Gathering
pension storm where we looked at the
trends all over the United States and
said this is all bill this is all a
bunch of hidden costs that's not only
hidden in the way it's budgeted for
because its future costs but it's hidden
actually by reports that are published
by state local governments of just say
well don't worry we're going to make so
much money in the stock market that will
find
essentially that's because we're going
to make double the normal average market
returns for the next 25 years trust us
so so our report point out well no this
is not likely to happen and in fact
we're going to face these these would be
we have real liabilities of maybe as
much as two trillion dollars at that
time and the reaction we got I mean just
even within sort of the economists and
and relatively more free market folks
there was a lot of skepticism that those
numbers could possibly be that bad and
of course it took about a year and a
half of more people paying more
attention to that to really what we
revealed that we had underestimated by a
good fifty percent the actual extent of
the problem so the overhang is huge and
the reaction from those government
employees unions was vigorous that is in
all my years of working at reason and
going and speaking and advocating in
front of testifying in front of
legislators and City Council's and
speaking in front of front of them at
conferences you know there's always
there's been a number of times when
there were sort of minor tensions and
and conflicts with unions but when this
report came out and we went on the road
talking about this report I mean they
got mean I had you know physical
intimidation I trying to speak to
legislators had them come up and stand
around me while I'm sitting just like
this in front of a group like this they
would actually march up here and line up
in a big goon squad behind me and try to
intimidate me into not talking and port
Lisa Snell they actually created a
barrier she was supposed to testify
before a legislative hearing they
identified her in the crowd and formed a
physical wall around her so she could
not go up and give her testimony when
she was called she could not break
through their wall of giant thuggish
bodies so she was back there saying I'm
here but I can't get there and the
legislature didn't care because what I
think they knew which side their bread
was buttered on so it brought
out the worst in these public employee
unions because it exposed the sweet deal
they had in secret they certainly knew
these numbers California deserves a lot
of the blame for that problem because it
pioneered these terrible policies and it
has reaped the most severe consequences
since I mean our incredible budget
problems we have in California you know
it's like I like to brag when I'm
meeting with people from lots of
different states that our budget deficit
is bigger than your entire budget and
that's true more than half the states
entire budget is smaller than
California's budget deficit so it's a
fine distinction and we followed up that
first report in 2006 that described to
the problem with the report focused on
california since it was at the bleeding
edge of this problem on well what are
some of the mechanisms that are being
developed to solve this problem how do
you how you wind down the costs of these
commitments how do you stop making the
problem worse because it is a tricky
business I mean those who haven't heard
me or one of my colleagues talked about
this before to think about pensions in
the arc contractual obligations of some
in some form and so to tell people
who've been working for ten years for
the state of California well you know
you were supposed to get this pension
well now you're not going to get that
penny that's hard to do hard to hard to
fight in court though even so even in
that dimension some progress is made but
they can certainly pay more themselves
into the pension system and we can
certainly quit offering those kind of
gold-plated pensions to new employees
and there's lots of other reforms that
can be done well it wasn't long after
that that state cities in California and
counties in California who really had
severe fiscal problems started looking
for ways to to make reforms and now
about a dozen cities in California have
passed some form of pension reform with
the the the biggest and boldest examples
being san diego in san jose now in san
diego some of those you saw the video
last night you saw
Carl DeMaio is a city councilman in was
until recently a city councilman in San
Diego and who led that effort he used to
work for reason and he understood these
reform ideas very well and he pushed he
pushed them effectively through in San
Diego in in San Jose a group of
reformers who ran for City Council on
the pension issue got into office
implemented essentially the the very
package of reforms that we proposed in
our reform study and then on a smaller
scale you had other cities just sort of
rain things in the city Bakersfield i
mentioned near where I live a friend of
mine who was on the City Council led
those efforts and shifted the benefits
for all new employees back to rational
levels required all employees to start
paying into the system along with the
taxpayers so that both were contributing
to the pension and not just the
taxpayers and so we're nibbling away at
the problem so California you know maybe
maybe that's the first step in I had a
couple of people essentially asked me
the question last night is you know when
as a nation or in the context of
California when do we hit bottom when do
people finally wake up and start start
demanding that things change and there's
a feeling i think in california now that
we're at that point or very near that
point we've got cities going bankrupt we
have democrats leading pension reform in
san jose and as well as republicans in
in san diego and other cities so it's
you know there's a broadening
realization that what we've been doing
doesn't work that we have to do things
differently in california that maybe
that same kind of feeling that i can
remember from before prop 13 this
dissatisfaction with the way things have
been going leading to some pretty big
and revolutionary change it seems like
we're at a moment like that in cal
fornia and it's kind of cool because
David mentioned last night that Carl
having very like insanely narrowly lost
his bid to be mayor of San Diego still
wants to do reform in California has
joining reason and leading a California
reform initiative that is a big we have
a ten-year vision for how we're going to
piece by piece in the same way that we
followed up cutting back city hall by
saying how do we piece by piece build up
the body of ideas for privatization that
makes privatization no matter where you
are and what you might want to privatize
something that's relatively easy to do
at least in terms of the knowledge about
what to do how do we do that for
California how do we develop all of the
reform ideas so that we have the whole
package of reforms we have the plan and
then how do we build the coalition a
sort of new majority of people in
California who recognized that the
change needs to happen and are willing
to push for that and then how do we
train the educate train the people in
government to adopt these ideas and play
that same rule we played in sandy
springs in Louisiana in Atlanta not only
developing ideas but knowing where those
ideas have been done how they actually
worked in helping with the
implementation helping overcome the
barriers helping make the case to the
constituents make the case in the media
all of those things I mean that's what
has always sort of set reasons policy
work apart is that multi-faceted from
the research all the way through not
just to passing the law but then once
the law is passed how do you actually do
the new policies once you change your
pensions how do you actually create the
new rules that don't dig you just dig
you back into the same problem once
again all that follow-through is crucial
if we do that for California if we can
turn California around not just fiscally
but just in terms of being a more
liberty-minded state being a less
regulatory state being a more business
friendly state being a lower tax state
that could be the kind of transformation
that actually answers the question of
when do we as a nation bottom out if
California turns around maybe that sets
the the course or sets the example for
the rest of the country and this this
sort of where do I get mine for free
attitude starts to turn to how do we
create you know a land of opportunity
again no thank you very much
you